Well, can everybody do another zoom call where are we try to answer as many questions as we can and by we I mean me usually
So thanks for getting your questions in.
Right into the question.
Okay.
First question for coffee in a bus if I brew the gold grossed coffee that you sell how long does it keep if I refrigerated before losing its efficiency.
Well,
the coffee doesn't really lose its efficiency so it's a cafe to the coffee that really works to stimulate the vagal nerve in the lower part of the rectum.
But it can go bad so it could get it key.
So as long as you seal it up in a couple mason jars, you know, where like a ball jar where it has a seal and you try to keep as much oxygen out of it, then it's going to last you you could get it to last a week no problem.
A lot of people will brew up enough for the week and that's how they'll do it so that's makes your life a little bit simpler.
So typically a week as long as you keep it away from oxygen as best as possible.
Please clarify what we thought you said about not Hodgkins lymphoma had stayed away from manual lymphatic lymphatic muscles.
Patient is currently doing low dose IPT chemo and the clinic has recommended massages to doc detoxify your insight is.
Okay, so you think about doing the panic DC talks to help with detoxification pathway so understand the whole detoxification process.
So from the farthest away from the detox exit would be the tissues so your tissues so your cells let's start there in your cells you will detox waste from the cell the horrible waste from normal metabolic activity waste from it like if you're.
Glutthione pathway is neutralizing oxidizing agents and then it will spew them out in through the cell membrane into the extracellular spaces so waste from the cells get spewed out into the extracellular spaces that's the spaces between the cells and then things move from there.
So only through motion of contract you contract the muscles motion of gravitational forces on you and that they move towards these open ended vessels like like sewers in your street that are called lymphatic vessels.
So lymphatic vessels then are just open ended vessels throughout your tissues that then pick up this and the waste will then be carried through the lip vessels and the whole live vascular system.
There are check valves so check valves allow things to go in one direction and then don't allow things to go backwards so how things move through the lymphatic system is solely through the action of muscles and through gravity so it takes forces physics to move something things will stay in.
And things that stay was only go into motion and motion is exerted upon them so exercise is so important.
So if you want to detox you have to move your body you have to exercise you just have to contract muscles motion is life so contracting your muscles moving even you know people that I'm you know take care of over the years that I can't I'm in a bed and I'm confined to a bed well if you could start writing the alphabet with your toes moving your legs and getting some motion in your body.
Any motion is beneficial to move fluid through your lipatic tissue now one thing we have to be careful about the cancer is that let's say let's say you have lymphoma so you have cancer in some lymph nodes so do you want to massage at that site.
But could you possibly be pushing a circulated tumor cells and having them circulate through your body well the answer is yes that is possible.
But typically circulated to their cells that go through your lymphatic system will most of the time be carried back or anything goes through lymphatic system will ultimately be carried back to your venous system that then it circulates through your liver to then through phase one phase two and phase three in the liver get detoxified and put into bile and then put into the first part of the small intestine that hopefully.
Go through your intestinal tract and exit into the toilet but can that be a possible way that cancer could spread well I would say you know you just think from from a functional perspective and I'd say yes if you're massaging the site of the cancer.
So let's say you have Hodgkin's lymphoma and you have one you know lymph node that has cancer in it it's your it's your neck area I'd say you should stay away from that and I've said over and over again people with breast cancer you should probably stay away from the site of the breast.
I mean you can still massage the arm when you have lymphatic stasis in let's say I'm breast cancer in the left arm and you have metastasis to the axillary lymph node in the left can you still massage do some soft tissue massage lymphatic drainage massage on the left arm sure should you do it in the axillary area where you have.
The test is probably done so just use some common sense on you know what a you know what a basically be aggravating the site of the cancer or do you want to be you know manipulating the cancer itself push it on the cancer and aggravating the cancer where it could possibly you know damage the wall around the cancer that your bodies hopefully try to create the wall off the cancer.
And or creating excess circulating tumor cells to be expelled by that tumor pass you don't want to just aggravate the cancer so I don't think there's any benefit to just just manipulating the cancer itself physically pushing on a tumor i don't think there's any benefit to that one so ever so I would just say stay away.
Regardless whether it's lymphoma or it's breast cancer you know whatever cancer you have to stay away from you know massaging that site of the cancer that's what that they should be teaching and I know that they do because I used to have a massage therapist that went through extra training to massage cancer patients and that's what they instructor to do to stay away from the cancer itself you don't want to aggravate the cancer.
It can become irritated you could possibly disperse more circulating tumor cells so just think of it that way it pretty much common sense um to just stay away from it but do any other lymphatic massage is fine um certainly understanding how your lymphatic system works normally you're not getting the soldiers to move lymph you are using muscles to move lymph exercising to move lymph.
Also this is where when you're doing chemotherapy or even IPT type chemo lotus chemo using other things to help you support those detox pathways i.e.
sweating through the use of sawdust using coffee enemas to stimulate phase one two three of the liver castoral packs over the liver to do the same thing you know the more things that you can do to support downstream pathways the better you can do most of the time when a person you know has not had a massage for a long time equals to get a massage then they can have a detox reaction I had that once when I got a massage because I'm like.
What's that very used to getting massage is when we went on a vacation runs several years ago and this is what I wasn't doing the greatest I thought well this would be good for me to get a massage well you know stupid me I didn't drink enough water and I felt sick the rest of my you know for the first couple days of my time away so that was kind of spoiled my vacation and it's because I basically stimulated the tissues.
To be to the libatic system to receive a lot of toxins from the tissues and basically overwhelmed my liver detox pathways in a sense I basically it was a hurt cyber reaction because I produced too many toxins in my bloodstream dead by liver phase one to three could get rid of.
You know and a greater rate than they could get rid of I didn't have any coffee at a my kit with me that would helps me a lot I didn't do have castor oil packs or how.
Packs to go over my liver at the time again I was on my medication that would have helped so I just had a drink a ton of water try to flush this out but.
Anytime you know go back to the detox the 7 phases of detox and understand those 7 phases of detox we've got to be making sure that everything down stream from that lymphatic massage is as open as humanly possible or you could just make yourself sicker with any type of massage shit.
What are your thoughts on the use of black sand for skin cancers.
Well I'm huge fan of black sand for skin cancers my wife used black sand for melanoma 2 spots at melanoma 10 years ago and I'm convinced if she did not use black sand for melanoma and ended up doing what's called a mose surgery which a dermatologist would do for skin cancer she would have probably little use of you know her.
Right arm from her shoulder because it was up on her right shoulder and the size of the tumor that came out after using black sand was quite large that she also had it on her left for arm at the brachial radialis muscle area and the size of that was quite large so.
To do mose surgery they go in and they remove as much cancer as they can visually see send it to the lab see if they have a clean mortar has to be over 2 millimeters a 3 millimeter clean mortar if not they have to go remove more go more well she would add part of her break your radialis removed.
And her left arm and probably would have damaged the brachial flexis in the right shoulder so she could have limited motion black sand spares all healthy tissue at black sand will kill cancer cells and draw that out now you don't want to do that have hazardly you have to be very careful with that we don't sell black sand in our store any longer be just because of safety reasons and FDA.
regulations that we do have black sand protocol and we can send people but we have to be really careful with it because it's highly regulated and you just got to be careful do it does cause a lot of pain.
I called immunolytics immunolytics is where is the company that sells the little petri dish plates where you could buy to test your home for mold.
um as you suggested after I did my michael talks test she didn't think they'd come up with anything different than the inspector we had over to test the molds in the house maybe I misunderstood why you want to be to do their testing in addition I suggested that you do their testing in addition simply because I was not completely familiar with everything the type of testing that your inspector did that.
suggested you at least call them and talk to them so if this if the gallon of your linux didn't think that that they would come up with anything different than that's just fine.
second of that topic I had elevated.
um citrinated ochre toxin a and this other um michael talks that I will.
really pronunciation on according to my michael talks test you had indicated on my last cheek swab that passable exposure may have contributed my cancer how would have passed exposure still be coming out in my urine are toxins stored somewhere.
yep yes toxins are stored somewhere so so when you're exposed to toxins of any kind whether it's poisons from the air that you breathe or chemicals from the gasoline that you just pumped or um glyphosate from what you just sprayed on your yard or what you just ate in your food.
or michael toxins produced from black mold in a building that you worked in 10 years ago those toxins go into your body now again how do toxins get out of your body rate of toxin.
um uptake to the rate of toxification whatever it exceeds the rate of your ability to detoxify then your body has to prevent some toxins cannot just keep circulating in your bloodstream so your bloodstream your then they they go through your.
you know your arterial walls they go into the extracellular space and they get stored you know all over your body so they can get stored in the extracellular space they can get stored in the cell membranes themselves the phospholid by layer of a cell membrane they can get stored inside of a cell.
um fat cells have an affinity to store toxins um and that's how your body protects you from you know basically becoming poisoned and dying from the poison it stores toxins typically in your fat cells that's the danger of losing weight too quickly you will break down um you know fat inside the fat cells and you'll break down.
toxins inside the fat cells that you'll liberate them into the extracellular spaces where they're carried remember by what the lymphatic system back to the venous system back to the liver hopefully then getting dispelled into the small intestine going to 30 feet a year attested into the toilet now there's all sorts of problems that could come up through that whole flow through that river of expelling toxin you can reabsorb them.
in the gut again and they go back into the bloodstream and they get dumped back into the extracellular spaces and go back right back into some other sim.
So toxins get stored in your body forever so you will die with lots of toxins so if you donate your body to some functional medicine test that they may have in the future when you die and we do a smear of your cells somewhere your liver we will find toxins.
There's poisons there so um but it's the level of toxins that damage cells so those toxins to all sorts of damage to the cell these micro toxins do damage to the cell they're oxidizing agents they can damage cell membranes if they get inside the nucleus of the cell member inside the cell is like a little New York City all the activity that's taking place in every single cell.
of your body which there's millions and billions and millions of them so um but the nucleus of the cell which is involved with replication biosis of new cells creating new cells um that can become damaged if any one of these toxins damages that nucleus that nucleus can one damage can cause the cell to go into rapid replication replicating cells.
that are in rapid replication that's called cancer so what causes cancer the answer is anything that gets inside a cell and can damage the nucleus and and uh increase the rate of replication of the cell.
So can be toxins can be biotoxins living organisms can be you know radiation can be lots of things so um they can stay in your body for a long time and then you can expel them when you start doing detoxification procedures you start living healthier that will help you get rid of them.
So let's say you do a mycotox test like this person did and you have elevated mycotoxins should you do something about it yes but most of you are already doing things about it you are already taking keylators and binders and things already have you on those things um so the truth is is that what were the question really is what were the levels of those mycotoxins.
Six months ago 12 months ago 18 months ago or years ago well we can't go back in time and go those things but the question is then where did they come from well that's why you got to find out whatever you do a mycotox test or any toxin exposure test whether it's a stool sample test or whatever you got to go where are they coming from um is it from current exposure
because if you have current exposure of mycotoxins you can be you know working on your detox pathways and and you know keylating agents and binders until your eyes turned green and you're not going to have a whole lot of success if your level of toxicification is the is exceeds your your rate of detoxification you're going to be coming more and more poison so you know
it behooves us to ask that question do I have current exposure now if you determine that you know what I don't have any current exposure this is all from past exposure okay well then just keep doing what you're doing you know you're doing some of this you're doing coffee
anything you're doing all these you know nutrition to help all this stuff up there's nothing else you need to do them okay you just want to make sure make sure make sure that you don't have current exposure
that's why I always suggest you know they're not that expensive to run a couple tests on your house look it on your car people can get these molds from different things
are you going to a church every Sunday that has full of molds and you're breathing that in are you going to you know a doctor's office that's full of mold
and you're breathing you know I don't know you know you have to place your lock homes and look for current exposure so nobody knows that unless you test for it
could it be from foods is another part of the question yeah can be so you know peanut butter common spot for
Michael talks and pick up so yeah you know I know people that are addicted to eating you know
giant amounts of peanut butter on a regular basis could that be an exposure of you know they should run a
Michael talks test they don't have any Michael toxins and they could probably continue the behavior
so that's what those other things you just want to be like a Sherlock Holmes looking for these things
and then run another Michael talks test you know if you have two Michael talks tests within a period of time let's say
you do another one at six months of your levels after all that you're doing are even higher you have some
courage exposure somewhere you got to figure this out so if they're continuing to drop then hey okay
well could have been totally a past exposure and it takes it does take a long time to get this stuff
are you familiar with Dr. Mindy Peltz's book Fast Like a Girl with my hormones coming back from the
block that was wondering if reading her book would be helpful since she takes the female cycle
into an account which seems more natural that perhaps could be more productive protective of health
overall I wanted to ask since there are so many health ideas that are okay unless you have had cancer
um I'm not familiar with that but it does make sense I mean you know honestly first time I ever thought
of yeah that makes a lot of sense that maybe at different times in the cycle are better times to fast
for a female so yeah that makes me interested to let a pregnant book and see what she has to say
what ways can I support my hormones better since they are all low
and now I'm having trouble losing weight I found a supplement powder called better hormones
below is a list of ingredients would this be good to help with balancing hormones better
to lose weight or do you have any other recommendations okay so first we have to define
this term um right here called hormones so we have lots of hormones in our body you know
what are we talking so um would uh so if a person has a cancer that could be
horrible related uh i.e. breast cancer i.e. prostate cancer i.e. um you know ovarian cancer
uterine cancer um should you be trying to get those get hormone levels of estrogen progesterone
testosterone elevated well maybe maybe not certainly that estrogen should not get estrogen elevated so
I think when the to understand this question I think the person is talking more about thyroid hormones
um so if you have have a history of breast cancer you should not be doing things to raise
estrogen levels typical now let's look at the supplement vitamin D well let's just find
vitamin B6 fine panathetic acid it's vitamin B5 that's fine chase tree very extract
now chase tree very extract is can be helpful to um that would be considered like an adaptogenic
herb help balance hormones i would say that's typically fine um so i would say that's fine
help extract that is not fine you know touch on that just a second milk test them that's good for your
liver allotero this is a um adaptogenic herb that's just fine too ginger ginger is an anti-inflammatory
stuff really hormone balance but they put it in here to help pull you know decrease inflammation
that's fine oh shwagada that's an adaptogen so that's fine so this this product is really what they
have in here because they have the kelp in here i think they're thinking about adaptogenic herbs
plus supporting the thyroid but i'm going to tell you in a second why you shouldn't use kelp
and altheonine altheonine is not technically an adaptogen but it's eaten a lot of adaptogens because it
can help club the brain and decrease anxiety which a lot of reasons why a person may want to be
under the adaptogen so remember adaptogenic herbs are classification of herbs that can help
lower hormones when they're elevated and help increase hormones when they're low and when i
use that term hormones i'm not talking about estrogen and progesterone i'm talking about
your hormones that stimulate your hypothalamus your tutory your geritals and your thyroid
so really when we talk about hormones we should classify them into those really those two groups
more your sex hormones which would be your progesterone your estrogen your testosterone pregnant alone
and those hormones that involve reproduction and your reproductive system and your hormones that
involve more your energy system um and which has to do with your metabolism and it does have to do
with weight loss which is your thyroid your geritals your pituitary your hypothalamus
and all the hormones that are released by those organs um you don't want to be using kelp
nor iodine if you have any thoughts of thyroid dysfunction which if a person has an inability to
lose weight difficulty losing weight it's quite possible that they have thyroid dysfunction which
really you should take a step back from taking any supplements and get your thyroid tested so in the
lab section of the member site you could do a thyroid profile or you could do the complete wellness
panel which i think is $122 which gives you a cbc a complete metabolic panel and a complete
thyroid panel so it's pretty inexpensive to get a complete thyroid panel and a good picture of
everything else at the same time because we really want to look at your free t4 total t4 same with t3
tsh and um uh tpo antibodies and thyroid globulin antibodies to make sure there's not a
hoshimoto's point are if you have low thyroid you should really be taking kelp at all because it's
high and iodide it will probably push you into a hoshimoto state look at the section on hoshimoto's
in the autoimmune corpse to help you understand why um but otherwise so i would use this supplement
if you're like hey i don't want to do a blood test i don't have the money to do with a blood test
just use an adaptogen so we have multiple adaptogens adaptive clear would be a good adaptogen to use
that's our one of our private label adaptogens adaptogen r3 from um from premier research lab as
another good adaptogen um to support them but really if you have a trouble to lose weight you really
want to look at the thyroid gland um you probably don't need chast tree for for that's not really
supporting the thyroid so much um this is probably not the best mix for you for not being able to lose weight
too so if you do need more help with that then feel free to schedule and tell me if you too that could
give you certain indications don't want to do but do it starting with that complete wellness test
would be a good thing because it has a value of that also look at it a dodge test where it gives you
a cortisol balance um that will be a good thing to do too a couple of weeks ago you mentioned
it could be good for me to take a binder when one it is good to take a binder when one does a
castoral pack okay so um so i mean it's good for anybody to take a binder oh your binder is helping
with phase five of the detoxification pathways so phase five detoxes making sure that you don't
reabsorb stuff that you're pushing that your liver is working so gosh darn hard to get into the smell
of the tested and if you reabsorb it your liver is just gonna go oh my gosh i quit i'm taking a
vacation i'm not doing this anymore so a binder will help grab on to it and hold it into the intestine
to be deposits or the twin is it best to take the binder before or starting the castoral pack or
take an after well um a binder is best to be taken on a more empty stomach um it's good you know to
take one in the morning between meals and maybe one in the afternoon between meals or you could take
it right before you go to bed that's when i would take it if using clear binder how many capsules would
you recommend taking i would just do two a day one in the morning in between meals and one in the
afternoon between meals or or right before you go to bed it's on a fairly empty stomach i said
didn't signature a test does it tell us anything i didn't get all my labs back but we'll get them
for you next week's call my liver enzymes went up a lot but they took me off the chemo pill and tell
after my pet schedule next Friday and then we will see if treatment is working um
yes you did send your test did uh what i did look at it but i'll see i can't read another one
so the looks like the mammals and can watch which is a good thing um so it looks like your trend is
downward so that looks like a good thing um the chemo pill wouldn't have an effect um would affect
the test results and also that would be good so i am interested in the pet skin so get that to
read them too and the labs we purchased it in for its son a therosage portable what temperature and
length of time do you recommend a person start at i recommend you started 140 degrees and that
you just start with like five minutes it and some people can't even tolerate five minutes if you're
like oh this is a piece of cake well you could push it a little bit but you can you don't want to
like be exhausted the rest of the day so because that can be you know not uncommon when a person starts
doing the son if you've ever done a son of before you can we always feel so good and then you're
like just wasting the rest of the day um so you just be careful of that so i'd say start five to
10 minutes maximum and ultimately you want to get do it for 20 to 30 minutes maximum person
everybody's a little bit different some people could do 30 minutes on us no big deal no problem to
me it's like i when i i don't do son is at this time of the year and the winter i'll do son is again
and i tend to not go more than 20 minutes and i tend i do not go more than 140 degrees
can we put infrared heating pad with castor oil pack on the left kidney where the tumor is or
would that be harmful um no i'd be careful putting um a castor oil pack at a heating pad
right over a cancer you know right over a tumor i would that person i just would not do that
now there's other practitioners say absolutely you want to get things moving there but
i mean there's there's also risk of i would not do that what's the purpose of that you want to
you want to use castor oil to help get things moving um through your detox pathway so that
ought to be the best place for castor oil packs is over your liver uh but talk to some of the other day
that isn't the patient that said they do castor oil packs all over their body it's like well
okay i don't know who has time to do that i don't ever recommend that i know we've had discussions
on this to do castor oil over abreast and such and i didn't necessarily recommend that but people said
they had some success with it okay well it's hard to argue with that but just be careful with putting
it over a tumor i have a friend who would like to know what is feeding his cancer but he is not
interested in alternative medicine is there a test he could do to ask his oncologist
no there isn't um there's some things that a person could do and i i think i write about it in my book
about i mean you know just do trial and error things i mean if if you're on a let's say a ketogenic
type diet or you know a ketogenic like diet and you know your six you know successful tests are
showing uh you know uh you know uh you know a curve upwards to be your cancer is getting worse
well then switch your diet you know do an opposite diet do a juicing diet or something like that so
you have to cut an experiment with that then and see you know what makes you feel best and what
makes the you know the tumor uh change you know some people that have a tumor that is visible or
visual or palpable it's easier to know hey you know when i eat this it seems like
when i've been comments from from many of you then you know with a breast tumor when i eat such and such
you know it feels like my tumor actually gets bigger and it feels irritated so i stay away from that
when i stick to this diet i just feel better and it seems like my tumor is going in the right direction
that's that's a fair way to do that now if you have a cancer in your test of tract and you have no
way of palpating or knowing whether it's getting better or worse then it makes it more difficult
until you're dependent on a cold test but you can certainly you know run the tumor marker test or
something like that to monitor progress what's the value of a stool test i thought i would call you say
our guy microbiome shape our gut microbiome changes so quickly in response to what you eat it doesn't
really give you valuable info well there's different stool tests that are out there probably the most
common stool test is a gut um microbiome test that you're talking about but more common than that would be
a gut um microbiome test that is testing for pathogens so it's testing for parasites
now that can be a valuable test if you have serious gut issues that you just can't seem to get into
balance now um even when i was taking care of you know more people with just functional medicine issues
that's not a test that i did on a regular basis um because most the time you know to me first of all
i mean yes you could have parasites that do cause ill health um but in truth you know
there's parasites that can't actually even be beneficial that affect one treatment seems really
weird but a treatment for autoimmune disease can actually be giving a person different
uh types of parasites um because when you have but you know different parasites living
symbiotically in that case if you it could actually help comb down a hyper immune response that
many people have a TH1 dominant autoimmune conditions um so it's not about i know a lot of functional
medicine doctors i did what they do parasite tests all the time and they're all into we got to kill
every parasite in your gut you know that's just you know you look throughout the animal kingdom
that's just that's just that always the case i mean animals live symbionically parasitically sometimes
and can actually help that the work the organism that is being found but it's not that all you know
pathogens or parasites are good for us but um certainly not all of them need to be killed and
need to be searched out and hunted either so i think it's better on getting the gut back in order from
an inflammatory standpoint maybe looking at got um things that are causing you know um got damaged
in epithelial damage which is most commonly not parasites it's much more commonly um uh you know
food sensitivities and toxins that have damaged the epithelial air and you got to heal the epithelial
air and get rid of anything that's causing a fire every time you let's say if you have antibodies to
gluten and you're eating gluten every day well you're causing this giant fire in your gut every day
there's no way i don't care how much gut healing products that you're gonna take you're never gonna
heal the gut if you're causing inflammatory damage on it you know every time you eat a meal so
you're running uh syrex panel 3x or 4 ray 3x or a 4 or a ray 10 can be highly valuable
to find out if you are if that's the case and then and then dealing with that so that you can work
concurrently to heal the gut remember we talked about this multiple times in the last six months or so
first place that you start with healing the gut is stomach and the HCl and the stomach because that's
your that's your number one um cause for damage in the gut and it's your number one
cause of the reason why a person would get pathological organisms from the food they eat um because
you know if i eat sushi that has worms in it that are microscopic and i can't see it or worm eggs
if i have healthy HCl in the gut you know 99% of them will be killed off by the HCl and my gut to
the rest will be destroyed by the enzymes it might do on them but here's the problem number one is
people don't have enough HCl in their stomach that's why i suggest taking an HCl supplement with each
meal something like clear digest or HCls or something like that because you will kill that which you
you know which you need to kill because your you know the acidity of your gut again they're one of
the main reasons why i'm against using alcohol water the acidity of the gut if it's above you know
a pH of 2 or 2.5 it's alkaline compared to what it should be it should be at about 1.0 pH it's very
highly acidic and it should kill any pathogens that it comes in contact with so that's the best way
to prevent parasitic infections to have proper HCl in the gut now certainly i i got a bottle of
our clear pair of clear um right here on my desk that i take these um i may take four of these um two
times a month just because they're good to help kill anything that passed by HCl time was deficient
today to take something and cause problems of the worst parasite that you could have is that
we're technically a parasite it's a bacteria that's HCl so he look back to Pylora is the worst
overgrowth and the most common overgrowth a bacteria worldwide number one cause of
stomach cancer in the world um top five reasons why you get endothelial dysfunction uh
aka heart disease is H-Pylora that's something that needs to be addressed and that's a major
reason H-Pylora overgrowth is a major reason for for gut epithelial damage and
uh aka leaky gut so dealing with that and that's where he used HCl again and burberry so that's why
I'm such a big fan of burberry because it's a cancer killer and H-Pylora killer and my dad
had been a heart attack at age 57 absolutely had a H-Pylora infection i mean it's ubiquitous
everybody has multiple times in their life and you just are keeping it at bay or you're not and it's
well we're growing and it's damaging all sorts of things and it's it's another cause of cancer
and more than just stomach cancer so it's something you want it to be addressed
if the AST and ALT in blood test shows 21 to 22 does that mean the liver is in good shape is
they're not congestion can we rely on these tests um well no just like any test it's just one test
so a person can have fatty liver disease and have normal AST, ALT and alcohol and phosphatase
that doesn't mean you don't have fatty liver disease the person can have liver cancer and have
normal liver function markers so it's amazing how well your body is tried to to live and survive and
and cope with all sorts of problems and your your blood work that is that shows on a CBC and a
complete metabolic panel is not a perfect test for for total liver function so AST and ALT will be
elevated if you have inflammatory acute or chronic inflammatory liver maybe from you know acute
toxicity you know I had one person years ago that I don't remember what they were taking some drug
but then they had super high AST and ALT numbers for a short period of time went off that drug and
everything came back in balance relatively quickly um but you can this is this is why people die
Tylenol poisoning you know you think oh well Tylenol is a safe drug or ad mill these non-steroidal
anti-inflammatories are safe drugs to take you know anything I guess it's safe it's all about
dosage and it's exceeding that person's dosage what is the LD the lethal dosage for that person
and everybody's a little bit different so if you you know do anything that could could cause
hyperinflammatory response in any organ that organ could shut down and that's why people die of
non-steroidal drugs is because their liver just basically shuts down and they have acute liver failure
they die so I mean last statistic I saw that in the United States a lot over 15,000 people die
Tylenol and ad mill poisoning every year so that's just them using it over the color so
these are good markers to look at but like any lamb it's just one marker so it's it doesn't tell
us none of the liver markers tell us how well the phase one phase two phase three detoxification pathways
are functioning you can still have congestion of the liver it's not functioning you know your
rate of toxicification could still be exceeding your rate of detoxification so there's no way to
totally measure that that's why we look at your genetics and look at those pathways to say
you're gonna be a slow detoxer but many people know that already I can't take this drug because I feel
sick if I take either Tylenol I feel sick well that tells you you probably got very slow phase one
phase two pathways you probably should not you need to be hyper vigilant about not taking those
things because you don't get rid of them very fast I had a blood test called D dimer so that is a blood
test measuring your epithelial elasticity endothelial elasticity quite come come back quite high
college is called yesterday and sent me straight to the hospital for a lung CT and check for pulmonary
embolism yeah so that's where you're looking for a blockage later this week I'll have an
ultrasound to make sure I don't have deep vein throbosis are there any natural things I can do to
help with this number nanoside lumbroside garlic so that's your biggest things that you would take
in this case I thought I was having any any stroke like type symptoms of any blockage type symptoms
rhomosis type symptoms I would get a garlic would be my first go to that's going to be the fastest
thing to work I just take a whole bunch of garlic now you do it to be careful if you're already on
a medication that's a blood thinner because you will think your blood quite quickly with garlic and
some people get off their blood that are just used garlic and you can take you should you know you
can take whole clove garlic I mean you could just go eat some garlic if you could tolerate it and
it can be irritated the stomach so you just have to be careful with that what you could get garlic
supplements you know just you know even once you can buy in the store over the cutter could be good and
and would be who you did to do that quickly and store a horrible stomach pain after take it ahead
and biotic a few weeks ago is it possible that inflammation from that could cause this yeah yes
absolutely it certainly can so make sure okay so if you take so this would be my kind of differential
diagnosis if you take garlic capsules and you get horrible stomach pain good chance you have it
also then you if that's the case then you want to absolutely make sure you take an HCl or apple
cider vinegar look at my post about that if you can tolerate HCl you use apple cider vinegar for
a period of time until you get tolerated and you get some got healing products like slippery elm
and deglycerized licorice to help heal the stomach lighting you know the pain in your gut after
an antibiotic could be two things it could be paid in the intestinal tract so if it's lower
down and you have pain from an antibiotic it could be damaged to the to the intestinal walls that you
could on the good side let's think of good things paid right at in the stomach so right underneath your
zyfoid process the part of the bone at the end of the sternum done by your stomach if you have pain
right there after taking it in an antibiotic it actually might be a good pain you might have HCl or
i in the antibiotics will kill HCl or i so so it's HCl or i as a bacteria so let's think maybe it's a
good thing however you get in a probiotic could be helpful too and certainly in order should be
on a probiotic river anytime you have to take an antibiotic take a probiotic with it um
and honestly just whatever you got just take it so um but i would also get a car like if the
garlic bothers your stomach still you got to be that's a sign that you could have HCl or i could have
a stomach ulcer you do want to do the other things i mentioned but still want for the vessels you
want to still be on garlic so eat some garlic with your food take garlic with the full stomach can you
please share via email a copy of your black sad protocol and suggest a good source where this might be
purchased no not unless we have a conversation because um it's not as simple as that you have to be
prepped mentally to start black sad and you have to be prepped um from a local perspective to have
a doctor that could prescribe paid medication if you so need um we've had people do black sad without
paid medication um and not need paid medication but a lot of people will need paid medication in the
last phases of the the tumor expelled itself after using black sad can be extremely painful
not because the cancer is dying there's no pain in killing the cancer cells with the black sad
the pain comes in in the cancer expelled itself okay so i'll give you an example
you can have a cancer that's the size of a that's round a melanoma that's round let's say it's
the size of a centimeter on your outer but it's actually underneath it's the size of a hard boiled egg
and when you start drawing it out the skin has to stretch and it can hurt like blazes and you might
be able to tolerate it with um some artica and and uh might overbatter during the day but you might not
be able to sleep at night for the last three days where it's coming up so you might need some
paid medications you need to be prepped so we don't i don't put the blacks at protocol other members
like for that reason because they don't want people using it then calling it haven't been in a crisis
situation so we need to have a discussion before you do that with edema our son is okay um yes it
so if you have edema let's say i'm swollen legs can you go with a son?
it can make it better but it can irritate it everybody's a little bit different by sweating
you could actually expel some of that water theoretically but sometimes you could actually
it could it can make it worse so you could try it i would just be careful um just be careful with it
i picked up the liquid aloe vera which has about 40% alcohol pretty intense could taste terrible
i would much rather use an aloe juice by myself would that be better? Sure give that a try um
yeah just if you can find a local aloe juice that would be fine you could also if you have aloe
clients you could you know make your own use out of the aloe plants too and any other questions
okay i think we will end there for the day thanks for being on um i hope everybody got
most of their questions answered about the true rife updates and everything's squared away with that
if you don't feel free to call our office it is for Angie um and uh look at the updates any
updates on the member site know that i'm praying for all of you and um i'm going to talk to you guys
next week